salut et beauté et bat ça y est voilà on
en direct on est bien avec mes à
villalier gilles verdez ya jimmy mohamed
pouvez nous poser toutes vos questions
les chéris je vous appellerai d'ici
alors il faut que vous sachiez que je
fais tout on en direct la sueur s'est
vite c'est historique 1 franchement
voilà voilà c'est franck dubosc ou
chérie tu as une questions à nous poser
mon franc qui prennent une case alors
c'est vrai qu'ici on attends attends mon
froid qui attend votre aide moi chérie
je vais sur jimmy mauvais alors la
question de franck dubosc on la rappelle
oui mais il se demande si quelqu'un est
malade à la maison qu'est ce qu'on fait
pour les autres pour ibra et que les
autres tombent malades on nous dit c'est
hyper contagieux il faut être honnête
dans la cellule familiale
si quelqu'un est malade il y a une
immense probabilité qu'on la trappe
surtout si c'est les enfants parce que
malgré tous les enfants autant entre
adultes on peut se mettre en quarantaine
mais les enfants malgré tout va
continuer de s'en occuper donc à la
maison c'est évident qu'on va tous la
trappe et donc pas de mesures drastiques
c'est un enfant a de la fièvre on ne met
pas sur le banc des punitions veut pas -
pas se dire oh là là c'est la
catastrophe
bon mon proc montfrin qu'est ce que ça
te va exactement
exactement on va on va venir à 4 nous on
est cinq à la maison on va rester à 5
confiné et puis les voilà exactement
mais 30
comme c'est parti ça continue ben ouais
tu vas rien avoir à faire bon temps
confinement et cette écotaxe à 28k qui
m'appelle à roland garros ça va mon
style mon frérot allant à saison elle va
être décalé parce que j'ai appris que
roland garros donc en mai c'était mort
tu la traite des noirs
bartoli ferro tu peux ranger ses
raquettes et bandeau qu'ils étaient des
petits poignets là c'est fini on tousse
tousse tousse touche jusqu'aux je parle
fâché avec quelqu'un très fort à l otan
pas ce qui fait qu'on l'ait pris dans
notre vie de notre routine dans
l'économie dans la boîte et le temps
passe et on n'y pense pas et maintenant
qu'on a beaucoup de temps je pense qu'on
pourrait tout se réconcilie avec une moi
je sais le coche pas si je venais de
match pas très conseillé quelqu'un on va
le faire toujours 500 euros ce mois ci
s'arrête une séquence à deux mains tu
vas te réconcilier quelqu'un après
demain j'aimerais conseiller quelqu'un
et gilles doit aller bas mais voilà avec
des personnes très
mouais si c'était moi je vous le dis
franchement ça serait mon père mais par
exemple on se parle depuis plus deux ans
non c'est vrai mais tous et tu l'as eu
tu l'as bien ces petites annonces mais
ça tu es incapable de nos micros tu l'as
eu ton papa là depuis la fois depuis
2001 crise on est fâché je n'ai pas pris
de nouvelle non normal c'est c'est pour
des histoires de famille de bêtises de
et il a un caractère c'est un peu toi et
moi il a son caractère moi aussi et puis
l'orgueilleux parce que c'est mon père
et puis moi aussi et on a généré un
texto en deux en tulle m
bah évidemment et puis vieilli là il a
un certain âge et puis tu as qu'une
trouille sais qu'un jour tu es un coup
de téléphone qui est en compte que tout
d'un coup bas tu parles purgeant tu
parles plus ta boîte parce que tu as
permettent à boîte tu parles tu de ta
voiture et de tout ce qui fait que tu te
concentres sur vraiment l'essentiel
bah tu te rends compte que l'essentiel
c'est comme la famille les gens que tu
aimes et là tu te dis effectivement je
peux travailler quelque chose oui je
pense que ça devrait j'espère que ça
fera réfléchir autant que ça me fait
réfléchir
tu as tu va l'appeler j'y pense mais
maintenant on en reparlera demain mon
chéri c'est que on t'aime fort et je
suis sur ton papa il t'aime fort et
qu'il est fier de toi comme non
définitive et je suis fier de toi
et en ce moment je trouve que tu un
comportement exceptionnel voilà moi je
suis fier de travailler avec toi je suis
fier de ce que tu fais à l'antenne et
hors antenne et je te le dis ce soir
bah voila je te le dis était vraiment
bien j'ai un caractère de canard ouais
mais tu es quand même mon ami es tu
resteras mon ami je te le dis est vrai
souci c'est comme ça tous les deux
parfois on peut s'engueuler tu sais
qu'on s'aime mais voilà mais tant
directs ont dépassé dans le salon et
chérie voyez dans le pré salon hier on
est dans le salon aujourd'hui 3
car aller c'est parfait ça chez vous
vous faites ça c'est le troisième
exercice à faire les chéris donc
ces cinq exercices d'une minute à perdre
4 1 à 4 catégories de nuit tombe y'en
aura dernier dans un instant et vous
faites ça 5 points
papa
si c'est trop dur vous laisser un petit
temps j y fais n'importe quoi
bah
o la même étoile a même été vouloir loin
l'un de l'autre loin l'un de l'autre
voilà à warhol lalala lalala
[Musique]
histoire
macquarie
[Musique]
oui c'est qui nabila au bébé comment ça
va ma chérie ma nabila d'amour ça va
chéri d'amour et ma chérie je suis très
content de t'avoir toi tu es août voilà
des atouts by ma chérie tout se passe
bien et embrasse fort thomas aussi avec
plaisir et ambroise thomas question pour
moi ça des matières y dans l'action
vérité quel est ton chroniqueurs
préférés
ça je ne peux pas répondre de en plus
surtout en ce moment donc je prends une
action une action à faire dix pompes à
la crème sous une assiette de crem alors
à bavois la balle alors là ce qu'on a là
c'est très bien il faut que je me fasse
à 7,2 traîne alors c'est très simple
faire dit ponte
voilà donc la assiette de crem on y va
voilà vous pouvez le faire chez vous ça
ça marche très très fort regardez donc
là je préfère prendre cette action donc
voilà dix pompes sur un ciel de traîne
si on pouvait mener une serviette il ya
quelqu'un qui est là attention c'est
parti attention c'est parti
2 3 4 ca c 'est mais non des
voilà on est blanc salut l'ami ça c'est
fait ça c'était de l'action on y va
continuer à m'envoyer vos action ou
vérité
on continue les chiffres ça y est je ne
vois plus rien je relève l'élu est fermé
traits de talent michel galy temps
maxime gagné loban à saskatoon
faut-il pas du tout lui les déchets rit
on a un problème sur ce fait ça à
haute-voix autre côté vous quant à
l'éventuel natale et reposé et hemani
stylo c'est pourtant j'ai eu un peu la
fièvre au revoir c'est pas du tout le
corona dieu sait quoi que ce soit mais
non on a l'impression d'avoir mille et
une maladie alors de nom avant la fièvre
n'est pas forcément le retour à la vie
rustique où va bien c'est dans le sud de
la france et est même le petit elliot
qui dit bonjour regarde il attendit
mignon ça rien et millions très minée
yao mon fils il a chaud d'amour ça va
mon fils chéri sam série et va bien
bah super choquant de voir un amour est
à vue il ya deux jours on va demander
quel film il fallait voir j'ai sorti
tout est filmé mais battus dans mon
salon je bombe avec mon chéri ya un truc
de ouf qui arrive à minuit parce que moi
je vais attendre ça je peux te dire je
me couche pas avant minuit parce que yes
carrey ewan minuit on attend tous est la
série du moment
tout le monde l'attend je vous jure
voilà on est tous en confinement s'il ya
un truc à regarder c'est validé la série
de gaston mille je vous le jure à canal+
il se dit que c'est la meilleure
création depuis très très très longtemps
et c'est mon franck gastambide mon
frérot qui l'a fait